crystal is in the the Ramsey baby-steps
community and that's the private
Facebook group that you can join if you
asked for it and jump on there it is the
official Ramsey Facebook group and
there's some fun stuff going on in there
my mother-in-law constantly has to
borrow money she's not disabled she's
not elderly she works full-time and
splints for splits rent with a friend
she always needs money and that's my
husband her son and he can't tell her no
what should I do go down to Walmart on
aisle three and buy your husband a
backbone that's what you need to do this
is not a mother-in-law problem this is a
man problem he needs to man up he can't
tell his mommy no oh watch family you're
supposed to stick up for family no the
younger your not if your family's doing
cocaine you don't give them the money to
do cocaine what's family that's what
people say when they're on they're
blindly supporting stupidity and
misbehavior and that's all this is this
woman is lazy and she's disorganized and
she is a travel agent for guilt trips
and your husband buys the ticket No
Boundaries not the boundary question
they're by the way and get dr. Henry
cloud on here we had him on here in a
while you know come on Henry help us
with these boundaries right he's a lot
nicer about boundaries than I am I'm
pretty brutal about them so yeah your
husband needs a backbone so it looks at
his mom and says no because he's not
helping her when he gives her money he's
harming her because he's funding her
delusion that her life is okay he's
funding her misbehavior he's funding her
not fixing what's wrong with her life
and I want her to fix what's long I want
her to be healed I wanted to win and so
if I'm gonna give her money I'm gonna
force behavior change that helps her and
causes her to be wealthy later and I'm
gonna give her a leg up towards that
with money but I'm not gonna support her
misbehavior
because I'm too what's a fight to tell
my mommy no man we have a manhood crisis
don't we